what is a dark place you've uh gone in
your mind in your life
what would be
the darkest place you've ever gone
for time
for a moment
and how did you survive how did you
overcome it
that's a very good question i i would
say
i haven't had as dark moments as many of
the people who i care for in the
emergency room i'm fortunate in that way
i've had a pretty you know
enjoyable satisfying life
you know i think everybody
um has dark moments though including me
one of the most shocking things i feel
like
becoming an adult my two big
realizations have been one no one knows
what they're doing and two
suicide is incredibly common like in in
all humans in all societies and that i
just find shocking i mean i've never
seriously contemplated myself but
i wouldn't say it hasn't crossed my mind
during some more stressful
times of life
i think it crosses everyone's mind and
sort of as a kid i found that i never
would have guessed how common suicide is
it's an important question to
sort of the uh the camus question like
why live
why
why
because like life especially when you're
struggling
especially when life is [ __ ]
like why am i doing any of this
and then on top of that chemistry of
your brain
it could be as simple as diet and
nutrition and
aforementioned exercise and things like
this that affect the chemistry such that
you're more predisposed to go to the
places
of asking the question why
and maybe um struggling to find a good
answer
because it's actually a question with no
good answer
except
something in your chemistry says well i
kind of like it but there's no good
intellectual answer
and especially if day to day it's pain
you get to see these stories of you know
robin williams
these people that are on top of the
world from an external perspective but
from an internal perspective
it's struggle every day's is pain
it feels hopeless and
yeah that's a that's a question we all
have to struggle with or learn how to
ignore maybe because if you ask the
question too much you're not gonna
you're not going to find a good answer
that's a choice you make i personally
think you should ask that question a lot
um
but maybe because i have the luxury of
the chemistry i have where i'm not in
danger
of uh seriously contemplating suicide
but why liv is an important question to
answer constantly and struggle to answer
that constantly
but people i am uh i've gotten uh i've
been extremely fortunate
to meet people
over the past couple of years that are
really struggling
and um
you have probably met
people who are really struggling
like orders of magnitude more people who
are really struggling
some of it is psychological a lot of it
is biological
and man life life is a [ __ ]
it's pretty tough very true
i do think also past trauma is a plays a
big role there like we talked about um
you know war wounds and ptsd and
a lot of people grew up
i mean which is horrific childhoods
they're abused in one way or another and
i think
a lot of people who have not not a major
i'm not saying a majority but a lot of
people for instance who i see in the er
uh coming in for threatening suicide or
actually trying and failing and being
brought to the er you know a lot of them
just have really traumatic experiences
um you know saw their parent commit
suicide uh were abused you know these
leave scars in the in the human brain
and mind and a lot of the sub their
subsequent lives of whether it's
substance abuse alcoholism etc is almost
trying to escape from their own memories
and
it's sort of such this overwhelming um
battle sometimes like sometimes
people get ruined it seems and just
can't be fixed you know what i mean yes
you can improve diet and health and your
life choices and
seek out your passion and exercise and
those definitely will help but sometimes
just like you know you bear the scars of
the past and there's no getting rid of
them
yeah
i think it's possible to live with them
i think there's a struggle i would never
say give up you know um keep fighting
it is a constant it can be a constant
battle for some people i know it can be
and i've talked to uh many of those
folks i know it can feel hopeless but
keep up the good fight
hopefully it's not a good fight
hopelessness is kind of one of the big
suicide risk factors that you sort of
ask about as a as a doctor you know do
you feel hopeless and that sort of uh
can be a harbinger
i have uh quite a few dark moments so if
you if you if you're listening
and you're struggling
we're in this together brother and
sister keep up the good fight
um
life is a [ __ ] as you said
it's really harder i think as a kid you
know in a joy-free childhood you don't
realize like obviously there's a ton you
don't realize about life
but then when you get to be an adult you
realize just how complex and hard it is
it this hard for adult animals i don't
know i don't think it is
um
so having seen
the honesty of biology before you
do you think about your own death
do you
contemplate death are you afraid of your
own death how do you make sense of it
i've definitely thought about it
especially maybe while doing certain
risky things
ice climbing and others where every time
i look down i thought about my own death
but
i think
you know i think having kids changes the
equation for sure
should change the equation perhaps so i
think a lot of
now when i think about what will happen
when i die you know there's a lot of um
worrying about what will happen to the
people i care for you know you think
about things like insurance policies
like life insurance and you know
yes disability insurance that's not
related to death but more just injuries
and
that's part of the weight i guess that
um you know you feel as an adult um that
i think grows rapidly when you have kids
though not only you know there's other
people you can care for your own parents
and loved ones like a lot of people
depend on
individuals and so you think about what
will happen to the other people when you
die
but also to push back
that weight
might be something
you've convinced yourself to think about
it's an important way to think about
but you focus on that way to escape the
other
weight
which is
that's
one point
this consciousness just comes to an end
and it's hard to make sense of
of that
we kind of delude ourselves and thinking
okay it just yeah it's ends that's the
natural way of things and so on that
makes sense so we're good okay that's
the way that's the way of life but like
i don't think it's like cognitively
easy to just realize how
terrifying that is
we we we love life so much
that
the end of it
it just um
it's something that makes no sense
and if you linger on that thought i
think it's a painful it's a painful i
would say even terrifying thought
not scared of like uh in a way that's
almost like philosophically terrifying
like it just reminds you maybe humbles
you that you don't know any of the
anything about anything
but one of the things we do as humans
really well is we uh especially with
kids
you realize okay we start caring for
others in the community and the family
and so on and that distracts us because
then we can at least focus on other
people's problems and not deal with our
own
uh
when i was a medical student i was
particularly fascinated with kind of
what actually happens as people die like
in the last minute seconds of life it's
sort of surprising sometimes like what
actually kills people you know like um
you can get a let's say a bad head
injury and um you know what kills you
sometimes it's just
your consciousness decreases and you
become
kind of comatose you aspirate
your oxygen plummets and you get cardiac
arrest you know that kind of sequence of
events
or
you know a heroin overdose
let's say you stop breathing similarly
your oxygen goes down then you get a
cardiac arrest so i was really
fascinated with what actually happens
what makes people die
and it was sort of a
morbid fascination obviously like most
of med school is
and i had many instances where
i've had patients pass um and as a
medical student i was sort of
sort of learning what's actually
happening watching it happen and you
know not only is always being able to
prevent it it was sort of a scientific
uh exploration
then the patient's family comes in and
are just devastated and then it's like
rips you out of this scientific
perspective and you just
realize how horrible death is but the
person's fine you know it's the family i
guess and that's why
um it's always i guess that pointed out
just how what people leave behind is
often kind of the horribleness of death
like just becoming unconscious and
staying that way doesn't seem
i guess to me personally so bad sort of
like going to sleep not waking up
not counting the pain and stuff that
precedes it so the actual pain the
actual suffering is often felt by the
people who love the person who died
right so both financial pain
psychological pain
for years missing them all those kinds
of things right never forgetting the
anniversary of their death you know just
having flashbacks or something reminding
you
that sort of
brought home to me sort of what death
means and it was more about what
people leave behind then what happens to
them specifically see i like
those concerns because i feel like i can
do
a lot about those those make sense to me
then just be if you're a father just be
a good father
uh
if you're sort of you mentioned sort of
insurance yeah there's like financial
stuff to take care of what i don't know
what to do with
is is uh the philosophical
existential crisis of the fact that this
freaking thing ends
it doesn't like i don't
know how to deal with the mystery that's
beyond death
why are we here why are we born at all
what is consciousness and you just look
at yourself what is this why do i have
the capacity to suffer
um
why why all these kinds of why questions
that don't have answers speaking of
which let me ask you a why question
the biggest ridiculous one what do you
think is the meaning of life
having with this book studied
the incredible beautiful biology of life
this the components the engineering
components they make up this human body
but when you look at the entirety of it
what is why
why are we here sometimes probably more
often than not feel like the question of
why is a trick of the human brain and
and outside of our thoughts there is no
why
why is not a something that's in the
universe it's just this trick happening
inside our brain
um so why why is the game that the human
brain plays on itself and then
the reality of life doesn't have wise i
do wonder if asking why is sort of an
evolutionary adaptation like um
why you know maybe hunting gathering why
does this plant grow there and not there
why do i see the same deer tracks and by
the same tree every three days what you
know why is this why is that
um
why does this plant uh make me vomit and
that plant doesn't i guess those y's are
very practical and oriented towards
survival
but then obviously you know we
not only use why you know we use it to
maybe hunt better gather better survive
better but then we sort of extrapolated
into these
unanswerable questions you know
um about why like why does life exist
and it's possible that they're not
unanswerable in the long arc of science
and history
it's we're just striving for the really
difficult questions right now we're just
don't know much about anything and so
we're striving but there there's long
so most of human history you were asking
why questions for which we now have
very precise answers
including with biology and physics and
all those kinds of things
and maybe the whys this cutting edge of
science of the explorer of the curiosity
of the human mind
like man's search for meaning is the
sort of
the ultimate driver of the why
and it's almost like it could be an
evolutionary adaptation of asking
exceptionally hard-wired questions
that will never get answered
like so you should always have like it's
like a cue it's a it's a stack of
questions why questions and that thing
should never come to the bottom
should always be striving
and that's that's useful for humans to
come up with better and better ways of
survival
and
maybe
from in a bigger perspective for the
universe to figure out something about
itself and it's just humans just a
useful tool for that
or life on earth as a useful tool for
that well
john this you're you're uh
[Music]
for people who should know you're from
philadelphia i'm from philadelphia so
it's an it's an honor that you would
travel all this way from a place i love
to the new place i love
and uh that you'll write this really
incredible book that celebrates the
human body in the most honest of ways
and uh thank you for everything you do
for being a great educator for being a
great doctor for being a great person
and for spending your really valuable
time with me today thank you john thanks
for having me lex
you